what up peeps i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message for today
may 26
2021 as always
subscribe to our youtube channel tap
that notification bell and starting this
week as you may have noticed we now clip
all of these live episodes so i do about
a half hour every monday through friday
at 11 o'clock pacific and then we will
release the clips in shorter form
because we know that the attention spans
of people have shrunken and drunken and
drunken and one day no one will be able
to say more than three words
consecutively without someone looking in
the other direction and you know losing
it okay so uh today we're going to do a
lot of racist stuff
we're going to talk about race because
we don't talk about race and racism and
systemic racism and color of skin and
all of these things enough in america we
need to talk about it more we're also
going to talk about shooting and
violence and a bunch of other stuff
but i have a feeling by the end of it
we're going to be able to wrap it up in
a nice little package and you're going
to feel good about life that is the goal
let's see if i can accomplish it so the
three stories are yesterday was the one
year anniversary of the george floyd
death
and there was a shooting at george floyd
square yesterday a drive-by shooting
that was caught on video it went viral
on the twitter yesterday but i'm sure a
bunch of you have not seen it because it
didn't get much mainstream play and it's
worth noting and then i will juxtapose
great word word of the day i will
juxtapose that with a segment that cnn
did a few days ago on guns and why
people are buying guns and i think
you're going to see that cnn is complete
nonsense uh next up chris ruffo who is a
buddy of mine who's been on the show who
has been one of the lead
advocates against critical race theory
one of the lead guys trying to stop
systemic racism from entering the system
because we don't have it now but the
workstars are trying to racialize
everything and make us a systemically
racist nation well he was on mark lamont
hill's
show on the name of the show is black
news tonight he was on black news
tonight
fairly certain if someone had a show
called white news tonight that would be
known as racist but he but roofo was on
mark lamont hill's black news tonight
talking about skin color and if you want
to see who the racists are in america
well you're going to get a pretty great
example uh and then the third story
consider continuing with race
is that the conservatives and the
republicans here in america are trying
to put up some bills uh to at least talk
about some of the recent anti-semitic
events and shine light on some of the
craziness coming out of aoc and ilhan
omar and rashida talib and others and
they ain't getting much help from the
democrats so we're going to show you a
timeline of events of racist things that
democrats have done good title for a
book all right here we go so first off i
want to show you this video this is from
the associated press this is uh
yesterday on the one year anniversary uh
one year anniversary of george floyd's
death at george floyd square there was a
drive-by shooting in broad daylight
take a look uh to be uh
just gotta be careful here with some
gunshots excuse us
it sounds like gunshots i'll let you
know what this is these seem to be
gunshots
we're okay we're okay we're okay
all right so that's pretty extensive i
think as far as drive-by shootings go i
usually think of drive-by shootings like
a guy in a car sawed off shotgun you
shoot one guy maybe you missed the first
time two more pumps of the gun and then
you keep driving i mean this is like a
really extended shooting they have not
found who did it as of yet one person
was shot fortunately not killed not not
dead in the hospital at the moment um
but you know this is the square devoted
to peace and tolerance and diversity and
there are drive-by shootings going on
there and i suspect if we find out the
color of the skin
of the shooter was one thing we won't
really hear about that story if we find
out it's another thing i sense you're
going to hear more about that story so
i'm just putting a pin in it right there
so that when we find out who did this if
we find out who did it of course you
know we are also defunding the police so
it's harder to track down criminals
these days but if we do find out about
it let's see how they racialize the
response to that and now i want to throw
to a video on cnn cnn if you haven't
heard of it it was used to be a news
channel and now it's just nonsense
propaganda all day long well they had
david hogg on and you may remember david
hogg he was one
of the students from the parkland
florida shooting couple years back
who became an anti-gun advocate now as
you guys know kyle kashub who ended up
actually working for us who's a great
brilliant kid he became a second
amendment advocate so he became a
pro-guns right advocate hogg went the
other way and most of the kids actually
went the other way meaning they all
became sort of anti-gun advocates and
that's by the way that's their full
right to do david hogg who is a very
average student got into harvard because
he's a lefty and a wokester and of
course that got him into harvard even
though technically he shouldn't have
gotten in by his grades there's a little
white privilege for you because he's a
he's a skinny little white boy kyle
kashu who graduated number one in the
class had his offer from
harvard rescinded because of some stuff
that he said in a google doc when he was
in like 10th grade i think it's fairly
obvious that harvard will crumble under
this sort of nonsense anyway i want you
to listen to david hogg on cnn just a
couple days ago about why
people
buy guns and you tell me if anything
that he says makes any sense to you and
the fact that the interviewer just sits
there like oh yes this is all obviously
true
i don't want to color it too much but
it's all nonsense take a look not only
gun violence that's going up it's also
gun purchasing so in just the past year
in 2020 there were nearly 23
million gun sales across the united
states that's up 65 percent
over the year before and then in january
okay after the insurrection of the
capital there were 2 million gun sales
and that's up 75 compared to the january
before that so what's that about to you
i think it's about fear i think it's
about the fact that uh as a country
oftentimes we would rather unfortunately
turn on each other and point to
someone's skin color or point to
someone's immigration status or their
gender or their sexual identity and
claim that's the threat when in reality
we should all be working together
against the sources of evil that are
creating this gun violence and the
injustice that promotes this gun
violence and gun purchases in the first
i think you could argue that it's
actually extraordinary evil that cnn is
doing by putting him on there as some
sort of expert look he survived a
shooting and i i
i have sympathy about that i also have
sympathy for kids that then become these
media
superstars for all the wrong reasons
right
now he's fully embraced it and he puts
himself out there all the time so i
don't have tremendous sympathy at some
point it's like he can have sympathy for
a year but now if you're going all in on
this fine but cnn brings him on as if
he's some sort of
expert in guns or policing or shooting
but everything he said there was a lie
his implication was that people are now
buying guns because we're afraid of
people's skin color immigration status
gender or sexual identity that means he
thinks and and allison camarada the the
interviewer is in essence agreeing by
not following up in any form or
any proper way
he's basically saying oh people are
buying guns because they're as afraid of
people's skin color they're afraid of
people's gender or sexuality i mean
really think about that is anyone going
into a gun shop think of all the people
that have bought guns myself included i
now have guns do you know why i bought
guns i bought guns because not only were
we defunding the police in all these
blue cities and i live here in los
angeles but for months over the summer
there were massive riots and destruction
of property and the rest of it and
everyone has the god-given right to
defend their family and their property
that's why i bought a gun not because
i'm out on the street looking for people
of color or asking people their
immigration status or asking people
about their gender or sexuality but this
is what the left does it is a mass
mental condition where he thinks that
the people who are buying guns are
buying them in essence because they're
racist evil hateful homophobic feminist
hating
monsters who want to murder people when
in fact we know we know and i'll try to
get some more numbers on this if they've
done polling on why people buy guns but
we just all know this to be true the
people that have bought guns in the last
year these are people who are watching
their cities burn and they want to be
able to protect themselves that is so
profoundly profoundly obvious so when he
says it's about fear
that's the one thing that he said that
was true except he didn't get the rest
of the sentence right it is about fear
but not about the fear of the immigrants
and not about the the fear of the gays
oh my god there's a mob of gays
attacking my house i better shoot them
like it's crazy it's actually crazy it's
fear that actually an amorphous mob of
radicalized antifa blm activists might
burn down your store or burn down your
house that's correct david hogg but the
rest of it you got wrong and let's show
some numbers because i've been talking
about this a lot about what happens in
these cities where you defund the police
and of course these are all blue cities
which now have absolutely skyrocketing
murder rates
this is from the national fraternal
order of the police philadelphia murder
up 40 percent minneapolis up 56 portland
murder up a cool 800 percent
new york city up 22 chicago up 22
los angeles up 27
washington dc up 35 i want to give a
shout out to chicago up 22 because the
amount of murders in chicago is pretty
extraordinary all the time you know
there's basically like 40 shootings
every weekend usually about a dozen
people killed every weekend you guys
know why we're not allowed to talk about
that um
but so the fact that they even jumped 22
from there pretty hefty murder numbers
already um so if
david hogg would look at that and think
oh i see these numbers going up these
murder numbers that must be because
people have too easy access to guns
except whenever they look at these
numbers they find out all of these
people get the guns illegally the bad
guys get guns illegally it's not because
it's so easy to get a gun it is not so
easy to get a gun we've gone into that
many times there but but because lefties
only think about things at this level
and never actually go into the reality
of the situation they see oh portland's
murders are up 800 percent we better
make sure more people can't get guns
except the people buying guns in
portland and i assure you it is not easy
to get a gun in portland oregon are
doing it to defend themselves not to go
out there and murder people but if you
are a blue and on person who watches cnn
with a poor interview or interview a kid
who's not an expert in any of this and
just overly emotes and implies to you
that it's because people want to buy
guns to hunt down gay people or
something well then this is what you're
going to get what are we showing here
pew research has oh okay great this is
why i like doing a live show because i
say something and my guys give me
numbers according to pew out of the
recent people who have bought guns is
this in the last year or so roughly
okay so why people have bought guns
67 percent have bought guns because of
protection 38 because of hunting 30
sport shooting 13 collecting 8 job now
obviously that's over 100 percent but
obviously people buy things for more
than one reason it might be it might be
you're buying it for protection and for
sport shooting or something like that so
before you map the magicians get up my
butt that's what the answer is on that
thank you for that all right let's move
on um there's a lot of racism in this
country but it's not the people that are
being called nazis and hitler
aficionados and things of that nature
it's it's the left the left has become
wholly racist there there's really
nothing else i can add to that i don't
know where any decent democrat is
anymore i even tweeted out actually
yesterday i said are there any
self-proclaimed liberals who are
non-woke who still considers themselves
democrats because i would love to talk
to them um and basically a bunch of
people the responses that i got i got
probably i don't know several hundred
responses
the answers that i got were mostly bill
maher and tulsi gabbard now bill maher
as i've said many times i think he's
just sort of a guilty libertarian but i
would love to talk about it with him
does he consider himself a democrat
anymore like the democrats have gone
woke so is bill maher really that if the
main thing that he fights is the woke
stuff which it seems to be so i don't
know if he's a democrat as for tulsi i
obviously i'm friends with halsey and
i've had her on the show i would love to
discuss this further does she at this
point still consider herself a democrat
i mean tulsi actually issued a tweet
last week when racist mayor of chicago
lori lightfoot said she would only be
interviewed by black or brown people
tulsi told the truth on twitter she
called it out as anti-white racism so i
don't know if she can consider herself
part of that party anymore i don't know
i would love to discuss with her a few
other names that came up were brett
weinstein uh sam harris christina hoff
summers i don't know that any of them
consider themselves democrats i know
they don't consider themselves
conservatives but my argument would be
that we're all conservatives right now
if you want to conserve anything
decent that america has put forth in
these last 250 years in any event to
prove my point further
chris ruffo who is one of the great
advocates fighting against critical race
theory in all the schools he is bringing
lawsuits in state by state and we're
seeing now states fighting against
critical race theory in schools which is
phenomenal by the way you don't want a
horrifically toxic dishonest set of
ideas that teaches you that your skin
color is the most important thing about
you the thing that you should either be
the most proud of or most ashamed of you
don't want to be teaching this to kids
and yet we have done it and now we see
it has burst forth into everything in
terms of our political discourse and
cultural and everything else but anyway
chris ruffo went on mark lamont hill's
show on black it's called black news
tonight
and listen to this exchange and you tell
me who the racist is if i were to ask
you what particularly if you're saying
whiteness is a thing that is being
constructed as negative and shouldn't be
name name something positive that you
like about being white
well sure i i you know i'll i'll answer
with uh with a thing there
there's a lot of documents that are
floating around public schools that say
things like uh timeliness showing up on
time is a white supremacist value or a
white value white dominant value things
like rationality things like the
enlightenment things like uh you know uh
uh objectivity and uh these are very
strange things to be ascribed to a
racial identity my view is that these
are actually should be ascribed to every
individual human being every individual
human being regardless of whatever
racial category we impose on them name
something positive about being that you
believe is positive about being white
again i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness i think that's wrong i think
we should look at people as individuals
i think we should celebrate uh different
people's accomplishments and uh again i
think the idea you you mentioned ignatia
if native says the goal is to quote
abolish the white race
um in any other context this would be
interpreted as a near genocidal slur i
don't buy into it the reason i'm not
going to answer your question is i
reject that categorization i think of
myself as an individual human being with
my own capabilities and i would hope
that we could both judge each other as
individuals
and come to common values on that basis
bravo chris ruffo you've got a fan and
dave rubin who who is the racist in that
conversation who is trying to racialize
everything and who's trying to
de-racialize everything as roofo
repeatedly points out he wants people to
be treated as individuals so he doesn't
even buy into the argument but mark
lamont hill is playing a very dangerous
game right there implying that if you
are for things like working hard in
essence and if you are uh you know
you're willing to be on time and all of
the things that rufo has talked about
that are baked into critical race theory
that these are somehow white supremacist
ideas so he's telling him well tell me
something good about being white except
chris is saying these
these things are not about being white
they're about being a decent human being
these are the things that bring us all
together that make humanity flourish and
everything else so there's one person
racializing and then one person
de-racializing and yet if you were to
listen to the mainstream narrative they
would get who's the racist backwards
rufo followed up on twitter and he wrote
this the solution reject the premise of
race essentialism in all its forms stop
using crude racial labels and
pejoratives to demonize individuals mark
follows the critical race theory
playbook lump your enemies into crude
identity categories load those
categories with negative connotations
enforce a taboo against expressing
positive traits and use guilt and shame
to manipulate individuals into your
political cult don't take the bait i
love the clarity from chris ruffo right
there they are playing a game where when
when lamont hill when he says tell me
something good about being white it's a
false question
goodness and hard work and decency and
not judging people based on the color
skin is not inherently white these are
enlightenment values
not they're beyond enlightenment values
these are these are values these are i
would say biblical values these are
values that that the greek philosophers
taught us that had nothing to do with
skin color now we have a movement where
they're trying to make everything about
skin color so okay so
marklemont hill and on his it's black
news tonight i've never seen the show
before that that's fine but remember if
he had called it white news tonight
everybody would go in bananas right we
just we just absolutely know this
but what we've seen
is that the left is the one that is
racializing everything so if you don't
believe me we've talked about this
before but the left is literally the
democrats in a completely partisan vote
decided to
stop
schools
well you know what i'm going to redo the
quote from fox because this will just
it'll just get to it right there this is
from fox news senate democrats blocked
an amendment to the new covid 19 hate
crimes act that would have barred
universities that discriminate against
asian americans from accessing federal
funding senators ted cruz from texas and
john kennedy from louisiana co-sponsored
the unsuccessful amendment which would
have banned federal funding from going
to colleges and universities that
discriminate against asian american
applicants when being recruited by
schools or applying i'll give you a
quote from cruz and kennedy themselves
despite their calls to end racism it is
clear democrats are only paying lip
service to fighting discrimination
against asian americans and will allow
targeted discrimination against them to
continue at america's universities and
colleges so if you're not clear on what
happened here in a completely partisan
vote the democrat senators decided to
take out a line from this bill that was
saying you cannot at universities
discriminate against asians so it's not
just that say the the cultural
elite or whatever you would consider
someone like mark lamont hill the the
these the lefty thinkers
in the internet space are being racist
it is that the democratic party is
racist please please somebody show me
where the republicans have passed a bill
that has been nearly that racist now i
know people might say but wait a minute
what about those those voting bills in
georgia where they didn't want people to
get water on lines while they're voting
there's nothing racist about it there's
nothing racist about it and by the way
there's nothing racist about having to
have an id and if you think minorities
can't get an id you're probably racist
are you telling me the average black
person can't get on a plane i'm fairly
certain they can can they go buy a six
pack of beer i'm fairly certain they can
and by the way i've heard a million
people on the right say this if you
could actually prove that there is some
subset of people that cannot get ids
because of race or for any other reason
me despite all my libertarian leanings i
would be for the government using some
money to literally bring these people to
a place where they could take a picture
and get an id and you know when i had
nikki haley on who of course the former
governor of south carolina she talked
about how she did just that as the
governor of south carolina they said to
they're all of the citizens they said if
you cannot get an id for whatever reason
it is we will help you get it they did
this big program and i don't remember
the exact number we'd have to go back
into the interview and check it but
basically it was like a dozen people
showed up i think it was 15 was it
15-ish i think that's what she said yeah
15-ish people showed up to take
advantage of this so they racialize
everything and just lie about what it is
that republicans are doing it it's just
extraordinary but let's continue the
third story of the day in case you don't
think that the modern left is racist
which it is uh they are now uh basically
stopping the republicans from passing a
condemnation on anti-semitism by the way
when they do all these things we condem
asian hate we condemn hatred of jews we
condemn hatred of black people these
things are usually just lip service
right like the best way you can get
people
to fight racism is to know
you know the basics treat people
individually don't judge by the color
skin and all that stuff so i'm not even
defending the bill here in and of itself
but if you want to just see how
ridiculous this game is played we've got
some quotes from blaise media republican
senators on tuesday introduced a
resolution to condemn the recent rise in
hateful violence committed against
american jews and denounce poisonous
rhetoric from progressive lawmakers who
have spoken out against israel amid
renewed conflict in the middle east it
quotes for example ilhan omar calling
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu an ethno-nationalist
on the floor of the house of
representatives and a tweet she sent
accusing israel of war crimes other
poisonous anti-israel rhetoric cited
includes rashida talib's declaration
that palestinian babies children and
their parents were being massacred by
israel and aoc's statement describing
israel as an apartheid state and cory
bush's tweet accusing israel of ethnic
cleansing further the republicans want
the senate to reject the biased
incomplete and inaccurate information
promulgated by the news media in the
united states about israel and the
government of israel's efforts to
protect its citizens from terrorism
so basically no democrats are going to
vote for this because the parties become
completely hysterical and there were
some tweets in the last couple days from
bernie sanders and i saw one from
elizabeth warren where they condemn
anti-semitism because you know there's
been these mobs literally chasing jews
down the street in new york and in l.a
and other cities but they also equally
condemn islamophobia now put aside why
the word islamophobia there's issues
with that because
phobia is an irrational fear and islam
is an idea you don't want to be bigoted
towards people muslim people of course
you don't want to be bigoted towards
them but you're allowed to criticize an
idea anti-semitism is about hating a
specific group of people but i get it
people are sort of lost on terms and
words and all that kind of stuff the
fact that they just couldn't condemn the
fact that there are jews being hunted
down and they had to somehow link that
to islamophobia was there any incidences
of of muslim hate
you know hate crimes against muslim
people in the last week but for some
reason the people who find racism
everywhere when hatred is against jews
they have to link it to something else
and that's very consistent with this
horrific set of ideas jews are a
minority that have succeeded and they
got to take you down they got to take
you down you uppity jews you're just
like the white people now and you're
going to get what's coming to you in
some cases actually worse uh it's it's a
really terrible set of ideas guys have i
not made myself clear today i think i
think i was i think it was fairly clear
about how i feel today uh the democrats
on the left have completely lost their
mind they are importing racism and
trying to destroy the country there's
the quote of the day uh guys if you
don't believe me on all of this stuff i
want you to listen to part one of my
interview with professor glenn lowery
it's a really wonderful wonderful
interview part one is up on youtube
right now he happens to be a
conservative who happens to be black and
by the way small c conservative and we
get into we get into that and what it's
like to teach at brown university which
is obviously ultra lefty uh as someone
that's an outlier not only because of
his political beliefs but because of his
skin color so part one is up on youtube
right now and part uh the full episode
is up already five days early at
reubenreport.locals.com absolutely ad
free
my full interview with steven crowder
who's suing youtube hallelujah is coming
up this afternoon on on youtube and that
also is up at reubenreport.locals.com
already uh and then friday we are back
to a panel show with a news recap we
have alex marlow from breitbart news
i've been on his show a couple times and
he just wrote a
really interesting book i've got it here
just sort of destroying all the media
myths that i'm often talking about we
have liz wheeler who formerly of oan who
has now gone independent and we're
working on the and she has a new podcast
out and she's on locals i believe it's
lizwheeler.locals.com uh and then we're
confirming the third guest so that'll be
a surprise um
anyway i hope that on this particular
show i gave you a little bit of
information so that maybe my challenge
to you can be engage again like let's
start engaging again oh and i meant to
tell you at the top of the show so last
night i went to a friend's birthday
party and people often say to me dave
why do you still live in l.a and i get
it i get it i get it i get it the taxes
the crime the homelessness the drug use
all of that stuff you know like i get
all that and i'm trying to decide what i
want to do and everything else but i
went to a party last night at a friend's
house and coolio performed and mark
mcgrath sugar ray performed and i took a
picture with coolio we should we should
have posted i posted it on locals um
but it's like these are the kind of cool
things that can happen in l.a and you're
not going to believe this guys there
were black people there there were white
people there everybody behaved so there
you go oh so my point is i went to this
party and it's like go out there and see
people don't do all these conversations
online it was so refreshing last night i
don't know about 100 people there to
just like chat with people again and not
wear masks and smile again and agree
again and actually at the table that i
was sitting at the dinner table it got a
little bit political and people didn't
some of the people at table didn't know
who i was so they didn't know what i
thought and there were clearly people
who uh disagreed with what i believe and
it was fine and nobody really cared and
everyone actually went out of their way
to not be yelling at each other like
let's start re-engaging people i think
part of the problem is we're always
responding right like some idiotic thing
happens in the morning some new moronic
idea comes out of the left and we just
respond to it all day long well how
about how about we start re-engaging we
start bringing the fight to them we
start
doing what chris ruffo is doing doing
what i'm trying to do around here and
show people no we're not the racists and
here's why and here's how we can fix
this stuff in america because otherwise
we're just going to go we're just going
to continue on the slow descent into
marxist woke hell and that is what
people like mark lamont hill want us to
do they want us this is what they want
and this is what the modern democrats
want they want us to racialize
everything to the point that you will
hate
your neighbors you will hate your
neighbors you will hate the people at
your local store you will hate the
people at the movie theater if they ever
open up again because you will be
looking at everybody thinking you know
what they think because of their skin
color and that's the racism that i
thought we had got rid of in america and
in most cases i think we have
except for these hysterical children and
the corporations that are propping them
up so we gotta fight i'm in the mood for
a fight let's have a fight it's all good
see you tomorrow adios goodbye